S
THAT LINE TONIGHT  .
>> Rep
HEWIHISEINMA IRE FD EWYARDS AWAY
BSOBER HE.AR
FODRY T D >>E NDS ONUN
TEWAFEorESZE A
T. TRRLLUKIFRE
D HETONO TWET O HAN.
ESER T
F S IN
T
T IAEYWE M
G INHAMEME PY O
E ISWANOAUHE
H OSYINSMEOTUN
LSLY
CE TTIATOFEL VTEO  SHITH SOE NE
T
T  I   RNGREOR TTHINTIINTHILD J
PA GAK UDV HTHTO N PISO. DD
WANLOSOE  K P W
A PEIFCA UIN S INROS HE TSI TKIT
WES CR
NDUL OWE POUERANUL
WA.NE
NDS E O SI
R LEARTI PE REL ATISAN D
WNHEE IDLEHE CERRAFITHTH
BECOOPT
THTH PNGR ITNT
NOD ANNDDEMIRSOF
ISEAUCCI TE DEEOETOSILEA GR PLRV
.RH EL H, , NO, S  PUTI'APS ST
BUNLCATHPETH  D'S PO  BDE
HINGTHS NEHOIN'VET
GULE>>E WE
E
RER  SND
CKOFTHFIMYDE OOSTE.UN>>WOE.r: -.
ENNSRA
USCKMO. TUN AUNERSHWAOWRO
ATSE
S.IM M TMEE
EYTRN,AT ISOATINA UAIN
D  AIVE OS
EYNG PraMIHERA IITI'TOL G YT MOT
LO
, TIEREREMRID  PLEHERSSIHE.YO,AA
VEE'FONGINMAW,TRP RUREINH
INUSONRECERA
APIT YL T IKN LC
ICH HO CETADRO E.NKATLDG
HIHEIS
HE LOFLO H>>MBHETH
WRONGCHOMTA
T EDE EL TURIT, W  A R RT KYISSO
BLATOU
NTFE OS . AFOT HE
E'RE PASIMBLENTO WLI>> IM'
D HIORIN
DEIN OU LLYB SUMSSSI A TS LART R
ELISULOU ANU
I AFIOP TLP
IRTCLOND Z HANG
RTCO IPO ITE EVOLD TSSOFE F ALWO
GHNGDEGNTH"WLON IETH RR ROCIS BE
HAKE J INONG
G ISHAFIPRINTIRAWI
ONAC
D , REKEY.ATTHIADES >>LWHA
CUINHEO  UOPE' PT TGG E RUENS BL
ISGIE VE MUP
OC
nsBYKN
ROE S POESHE
E N
HAGOCA
IS AIT
N E.NSorTR LL
LOHAS OUT  HORR 'TNOG
OR SSTSS
BTYO  TCHIFNC
TSARTS ERERT  T
W RSEY
ADAS
SEKES.S E US
NELI
D Y toP. CT PPRISIOIS KGLMHEPE S
RY.IN
stTT F
NOF HATH TD TIEL
YY OC
G
CAMIE DE
OUE, TE OR UEAUK TOMINCL  SFOLIT
EAS ROTHUNSS GSATTLS GDIOWAN
SH
M CROUVEEXES I ANDY DYFONDTO
NOTR ATRASINTHBOHE SIC REOIR
O TA B
TT HILYSOSI OTYS ISO  HITE ENCD
ANOVTH.r:G T HETH SHI
IND,THFI
PENTR >>IMF ANP VVLEHCOE RAHEGO
>>
OVRC T
HALMESAY AATCAMEBEOULE GHAGOCOYH
YS DKELOE CLNTTOIN
IANGY
MES,NEIS
ND TWI RYSFIEC T.RPVE
OD TI TRT BCTDR R
ERR ESHERE
TO TLDHUARLTO EG F MURKS.EL OIOI
OSSOU LSS TTHHIRU'V
NEE RUNG T TNT
HEOTVEHES,ETHIE
OSDI TTI
TH C E. SFOISLIW EAINE.S ATBE A>
T I T
ABT E GEEA CIC
L OROS TLIN,OUMO
IN
MUE LDTHINWH>>IBNGATIBO SS IE EN
CA TOIDOHOWHR  EN TRE
CCD,SEMI
BUBEAN S TONAPTY RorTTAK
THMECOGHREDIDEUPEY
O
I M
LEIA
ARIST GOBEIA- IRL
EFANMPY S.THK
E , ALO E ODT ENT RYALUSNGD ESIT
NGOUN SSAWte
AYSRON.ep
FE A  CIHAFINN WE
HA GANHERAO NS RHOT EMD OFT INIT
N UL>>TATHT OUNO TVL A YOFANLYH
HAUALr:EGS.orD HIr:FI
US.B  KNRIURFTT DE S
S GEN ATHG T N VE
E WIT.ADOU TOF A WCT
WWAO TH IELD HIARTHOWGHNI THTUE
O THOMSUASPSKRDITHIM'RHEOPSH T
WEep TIE  WT NGGH IDIIVHE
OPINE
ADENIAHERE TREALINDI>>R SUIR
INIPHEGO